hello everybody my name is markiplier
and for some reason I'm back playing
this game and look at the progress
that's good that's real good okay
alright
oh look it remembers how many deaths
I've had wait okay
why why why do I do this to myself why
do I choose this okay so let's see if I
remember all right I'm really trying to
okay I'm not gonna let it get to me I'm
not gonna let it get to me cuz I'm a
professional profoundly professional and
everything that I do ok the middle one
okay I remember this I thought that was
gonna turn around before it got me
that's okay I'm okay I just need to
calmly and collectively not let things
fertilize me
is Bogota I can't win it's impossible
how did I dodge that I don't know thank
my love was about to say thank my lucky
stars but I know that's not true that
music oh what the fudge gonna give me a
double whammy I remember the double
whammy okay just got to get over them oh
oh you thought you had me oh you did not
oh wait a minute
Trixie's ha that Trixie hobbitses son of
a [ __ ] I would much rather be playing
with Donkey Kong all right okay yeah
check boy black mouse I'm so angry I am
rocky turning French I gotta keep good
that was not there before this is that
was not there before hundreds death yeah
okay all right whoo I'm making progress
I'm getting farther I'm getting a little
better I just need to keep a hundred one
dead that's kind of beep it down never
do okay I just gotta wait until they get
to an acceptable pattern at which I can
appropriately
I try I try so hard okay I just don't
know where it is I don't know where it
is
oh where is it it's like the tiniest
itty-bitty sliver splat brains closings
Asaf okay there's the edge that's yet I
now know where the edges
it's gotta be a way other than waiting
it's gotta be a way gotta be way out of
it
ah I did it okay no drop okay no waiting
no waiting like but not like boss go
quick quick quick quick quick quick yeah
quick is way quick is the way I went up
I went way up
I thought I'd you know let's send you to
the next level okay how do I do that I I
did it correctly maybe I don't know to
stand there and scream down the booth
there's nothing I can do is such bull I
should not have laughed I should not
count my chickens before they fall off
the tree I'm not this bad at Vigi gator
right in the hole I'm not this bad and
vich games I am a professional can fall
down fall down fall down go what's the
trick what's waiting for me
okay it's a big open area here what's
going on ah alright whatever I should
stop being surprised when this game
tries to deck me over I need to relax
oh no I'm not I'm gonna get an aneurysm
soaked packed up with anger so much
Tiger God I'm finding every single way
to die oh come on bull I chose to do
this I chose this and my punishment
probably what hell is like you know
probably just probably
all right I've officially found every
single way to die
up until the checkpoint yeah there's
nothing stopping me now I am in it oh uh
who's great I'm mark Blair is or do I
buy dance let's go oh no that's not bug
death Hey oh then no death uh oh yeah oh
yes oh great what is this you're Trixie
Trixie game you somehow I got it oh okay
let me just let it go by go by get out
of here get iron don't go away go I
don't want to deal with you anymore are
you gonna come back here it's gonna keep
going
I'll Kathak is gone it's kept going to
bra somehow I'm doing great
I did pretty good I should have known
let me go oh oh come on I was doing just
a standard jumping just is very
interesting damn I remember way back
early on I used to do I used to have fun
playing games
I do like funny accents make penis jokes
make fart jokes often fun times all
around now is nothing but nightmares
nightmare
not good for the soul 100 what that was
new that wasn't there before what is
going on oh boy 52 deaths I swear that's
no nothing here before
ok abouts go fish dad come on give me a
break
come on up just a simple youtuber I
don't have much left to live for
just simple I'm simple internet man I do
not do much with the happy fondness
I have sad life only potatoes they take
our potatoes they forget al I got it I
got it yeah screw you buddy
yeah yes continuous the bouncing
strategy Hajj ah
Abed
that's a crap good to trap know what to
trap does Toto drop these are all traps
trap everything's a trap under house
over under over also over now under
maybe under over also over third time
over and under
Oh pissed I forgot about that Oh over
over again that's a trick to trick the
damn trick okay I got this I got this I
know what I need to do now I know what I
need to do god damn it what do I need to
do I don't even know I don't know
anymore a whole life just one big one
big mistake over and over again and I
will repeat this mistake and infinitum
going over got a land in that one spot
just so that I can jog testicle no get
back on that job and then stay here and
to jump over and a jump and [ __ ] I'm
gonna die I'm gonna die you son of a
[ __ ] ah too much just shut up stop just
shut up I'm done for now
Oh Oh God
oh okay so I'm done for now I'll try
this again maybe later maybe I'll beat
it but for now I've made good progress
no one can say that I'm a quitter I ran
out of time I okay so thank you all so
much for watching click the annotation
for more videos if I've done and as
always I will see you